let's talk a little bit about the
trajectory the future trajectory of the
White House coronavirus task force the
news is that Donald Trump is now
thinking of canceling the White House
coronavirus task force even as deaths
again spiked yesterday 220 350 in a
single day and this is this is like much
of what Trump has done in the last two
months when it comes to coronavirus
which is just a bad boneheaded idea but
if your concern is just propaganda and
pretending that you're doing a good job
instead of dealing with the virus this
is exactly what we would expect Donald
Trump to do the task force I'll remind
you was formed at the end of January
this is the task force where Mike
Pence's I guess the official head of the
task force dr. deborah birx is the
response coordinator you've got the
Surgeon General on the task force you
have that Secretary of Health and Human
Services Alex SR on it he's the one who
initially put a former dog breeder of
labradoodles in charge of the day-to-day
doctor foul cheese on the task force the
Commissioner of the FDA Stephen Han is
on it ben Carson is not there's a whole
bunch of people on this task force now
as it is the task force has not been
super concerned with health and has been
too concerned with politics towards the
end of the press briefings we would see
dr. Burks become more a vector of
disinformation than of science and that
was a horrible thing but at least you
had a task force that was briefing us
daily well the press briefings went
horribly wrong after the bleach
injection Fiasco we've seen those be
pared down really stopped at this point
we no longer see doctor foul he or dr.
Burks daily other than in corporate
media interviews and instead Donald
Trump has replaced the coronavirus press
briefings with these economic I guess
I'd call them economic agitprop events
with business CEOs and other
brown-nosing sycophants but the cases
aren't going down so if you are
prioritizing paying attention to the
data rather than whether Trump praises
CEOs we are still finding about 25,000
new coronavirus cases basically every
single day so I'm
times more sometimes a little less and
deaths again have spiked yesterday
twenty-three hundred and fifty deaths in
one day in the United States a really
bad number and when you look at what's
going on in Italy when you look at
what's going on in Spain when you look
at the curves and then you see what's
going on here it's not good and
meanwhile as I told you yesterday CDC
and FEMA have a report which says they
fear that deaths might actually climb to
3,000 a day by June first with maybe
200,000 new cases a day now I hope that
doesn't happen as you all know politics
don't play a role in what I hope happens
I don't hope we have one single death
for the purpose of making Trump look bad
or helping to defeat Trump the case for
that is very clear there have been
enough deaths I don't want anyone to die
hopefully it won't happen but the
numbers in a lot of states aren't
looking good here's Donald Trump asked
yesterday in Arizona about the
coronavirus task force Trump stopped at
a Honeywell mask required factory he
refused to wear a mask I'll talk about
that later but Donald Trump again
talking about we've just done great
about everything and at one point he
Trump walked around all day yesterday
with a piece of paper in his pocket that
was just a graph of the total number of
coronavirus tests which is meaningless
right we've talked about per capita here
is Donald Trump's answer and it includes
pulling out that piece of paper when
asked about why would you now disband
the coronavirus task force everything
and don't you want to I need I just want
to say that we've done an incredible job
in testing with that being said we have
some additional including antibody tests
coming out that will even blow these
numbers away but nobody's done the job
we don't you need to continue to meet
with the task force to get this
scientific expertise
we will have certain people as an
example we have hospitals that we built
we have medical centers that we built we
have people on the task force that focus
on that we have people on the task force
that's focused exclusively on
ventilators well we have more
ventilators now than anybody in the
world and we're helping France as you
know we're helping France Italy Spain
Nigeria we're just we're giving 250 to
Nigeria we have many countries that were
helping but the ventilator problem is
also you don't need that we have now a
different it's sort of a combination of
safety and reopening so we'll have
something in a different form but the
task force for what we've done I think
everybody out there when they're being
very honest I think the job we've done
on testing will shortly be and maybe
even supersede the job that we've done
on ventilators which people can't even
believe we had a call the other day with
the governor's so it goes on for about
an additional minute but as you can tell
there's no answer there's no answer the
question was should you really end the
coronavirus task force when we are in
the middle of a pandemic and Trump says
governors are happy we have tons of
ventilators and I have a piece of paper
with a graph about testing it's striking
me as counterintuitive to end the task
force now and I want to point out one
other thing we've been watching the
numbers coming out of some of these
early openings southern states the
states that didn't have these are states
that weren't initially hotspots and they
insisted that they're good to go and
reopen the numbers aren't good look at
just one example out of Texas in Texas
cases have increased dramatically over
the last nine days Texas had 535 new
cases on April 27 that went up to 960
new cases on April 30 and that was up to
more than 1200 new cases yesterday now
understand the raw numbers are not the
important thing here the percentage
increases are if you see new cases
continue to increase in Texas at this
rate they're 34,000 cases will be more
than 50,000 cases just ten days from now
and by then if
the other northeastern and West Coast
states keep seeing declines Texas will
have dramatically more active cases than
any of these early hot spots we can do a
similar analysis in other states I hope
none of this happens but the last thing
you need right now is to end the task
force and just focus on reopening since
its that reopening which may indeed
wreak havoc in a whole bunch of states
hope it doesn't happen it's what the
data is pointing to check this out the
first 500 people who see this video and
go to david pakman.com slash skill will
get a premium membership to Skillshare
for two months completely free skill
shares the online learning community
with thousands of classes on almost
anything you can imagine always taught
by experts they have classes on drawing
painting photography video editing web
design running a small business and much
more I recently took a very interesting
class called simple productivity how to
accomplish more with less and got a
bunch of great personal productivity
tips out of it we should allow ourselves
a little time every week to either get
creative keep your brain sharp learn
something new it's great for mental
health and almost all the classes are
under an hour so it's very easy for
someone who's busy to take advantage of
it with skill share you can discover a
new passion explore something you didn't
know you would enjoy but there's also
plenty of classes for people with
experience so you can just get better at
something you're already good at and
again the first 500 people who see this
video and go to david pakman.com slash
skill will get a completely free premium
membership for two whole months giving
you access to every class Skillshare
offers check it out I put the link right
underneath this video